[music]
we lived in a big bellows that we strengthened all the
time
and it seemed to us that life was quite
comfortable, we didn’t fully realize
what kind of society we live in,
are such monsters created
[music]
on apple tv in the sixth you start sex
on  the language is cohesive and actin
bifa itachi whether to appeal against the
accent facade near the office or
sergey troshin you are familiar on guard in the
positive this is clans physicists and knew that
this reactor
has such a property such a
defect
unfortunately the staff was not
fully aware of this about this  the sum of a
large number of errors the dispatcher did not
give permission for a long time at low
power a defect in the reactor itself the personnel were
not notified of such possibilities it
all happened exploded
[music]
he pays for the massive
serengeti bomber
[applause]
[music]
and when
oleg trukhanov you sextile throw
his legs at him construction slaughter from the fans
viktor
bryukhanov the plan was turned out that is, at night i
the coward heard only two or two calls, the
coward turned us off
and turned on the light, there was something, they began
to walk quickly, well, that is,
some stirring began, the door slammed and the
father left, that is, the bus came for him,
he just got on the bus and went
iphone se
but  and for questions about ron combines
this old type of screen tasty holes
tribes and females I will pick up
he was sleeping albus slepoy
[music]
it was night my wife picked up the phone I
did not hear myself saw the emotions of my wife who
said that something incredible happened
at the same time when I was driving  i didn’t see the
fire there was a certain feeling of a faint
glow over the destroyed block but it’s
insignificant the
people who were here the
main task was to understand what happened to
understand it’s impossible we won’t see the iphone
donation for the son against are like a city
spar compe risperidone same one max
and sandra  some language mold in multiply 7
astronaut killers stay start
appreciating it border cancel
after form 2 anneal for us give them
salihin km atlant rank went  a man and he
said that they would be born very high, more than
two hundred x-rays an hour, I didn’t believe it, I
also didn’t believe, just like Burkhanov, that
the radiation level was very high people were
very
this man came very excited
he was a specialist,
I always scolded myself for not  I believed
him because to perceive that radiation of
such a level
my brain did not perceive dead new, therefore
he was under the pressure of his
own, I actually had him
his professional
self-image did not allow him
to quit work without completing work, I would say that he
is to blame as a leader of
all of us  guilty as managers we
set to work without fully understanding
how it works is a criminal I
think not
[music]
usually usually stops were made common
also that's when I ran out to the landing of the
stairs to go down to
me surprisingly I still remember it well
sort of like  something stopped, sort of like
inside something said in general that it would
not be good, and we have  sl was, well, something
won’t work in my
equipment now and they’ll remove such a
banal question then I went down it all
went working there and for you that’s where the
trouble
death of wine expert and everyone
taught a
lot for reactions 1g if it stands with
bubbles behind influence  is a consistent
activity taipei sporting cutting five
there is such a circle here 0 4 laps 6
there were explosions there but respect flooded here the
roof was on fire there part of the roof was not
it right into the sky
one of my colleagues who was
on the block at night was it possible after the explosion did not
hear the roar look up the video that
it falls  the concrete slab began to run away
, this slab fell while he held
it so that 5 several tiles for
another like dominoes  he fell down
because of his illness,
we went about our own business,
no one else would do it, we know what
to do I knew what to do, he
knew what he had to do and everyone
did it why so many irradiated and
dead no one ran away, did not hide,
did it regardless  no matter what questions
mash hall was on fire the roof was smeared on fire it
didn’t matter whether it was possible to work worked everyone
localized all this you understand
[music]
[music] the
parties rested at our place they raised the
alarm and said tanning is not northup you need to
know the explosion happened arrived there the
guys left there the roof was on fire  marzolla
between the third and still there
[music] the
guys put out why the chat will send it
itself why where is the radiation then the decision is shorter
in half an hour they started to go down there the
stairs were
already broken they started
going down there the complexion is such or
brown or blue ph is such
and vomiting and fell  there it was necessary, I helped to
shoot this combat there to develop them, the ambulances
came and
took them away to find on the candy wrapper the signaling
ships and remember  find the phone
to enter
our superiors, here is the head of the unit,
he didn’t consider us people, I stood there
near the block, the
head of the unit passed and the chief inspector
gave me against and gave his to you, you
’ll still be useful to me,
but
they left their questions themselves to solve the
shelter, it will probably be water
blog,
well, our guard, all the guys
at me
[music] were
silent for nothing to anyone
May month, they built me according to their kind, they
ettled me, I don’t know, they knew well and plop,
but he knew, well,
in short, it’s not a good thing, well, or to me, that is, I saw
my father this is how I saw him in the eveni
g  On the 25th, then the next day, on the 26th, we
arrived in the evening, my grandfather came here on the 12th,
here he was standing in a suit in the
bread of which he went to the station, well,
change of clothes and he probably
aged 15 years, something seemed to me that he was all
haggard literally for  a day before also
fill
intrepid live in visual
[music]
doctors wax dance
seven in unity but also articles
[music]
went to school come to me my still such an
interesting case me  mom says
take a hat and freedom why take a hat
there glide radiation she takes a woolen hat I
take
clothes I go out into the street I take off my hat in a
briefcase I put it
in school I immediately teachers stones
years that how what happened era I do
n’t know anything they say so aware of some kind of
accident  seriously, but what and how I had no
idea then they already knew two lessons we
stayed and then everyone dismissed us
[music]
driving past the reactor he looked at and
on the reactors says this is my prison
he probably was ready for a friend everything was
never taken but never answered  but the fact
that for what he was imprisoned, as it were, for negligence,
for not sitting out people, that is,
you didn’t give your consent from the bead of
drying up, but we, firstly, we live with the
administrator, he didn’t stand at the console,
he didn’t sign this program, he was
man and the whole city to the ground also I
wash even further with wine
so that the director
attention attention attention
I feel sorry for him and my comrades
at the Chernobyl nuclear power plant
in the city of Pripyat
floating unfavorable radio
rating statistics for fttx beach and already
yours nods pieces of smoke
[music]
citizen your account or get
documents and fingers faster
download fifa for 6 - they said for three days and
wait 33 years
with heel locks from find stop on
stone shoot and spigen  and figurin
waltz expanded to usb cable
or qualities of the wild you are not, I
promised
[music]
I remember most of all when we
flew over Pripyat, this is the city
Pripyat was evacuated, but everything is like in the frames of
some kind of Martian
linen hanging on the balconies drying here
bikes cars are abandoned, that is,
people were here and they simply are not there
left separate objects that
indicate that there is no life here in
china was our grid on a simpler nissan
duane
and pays pipe calculations for you
answer the council of ministers fill in g
minor
andami  shouting stopped classes
[music]
music us of distant was looking for this
sprouts the greenery of the forests and with it a bunch
for there'sa last
[m  the
first contribution in Moscow by fires and which,
with their own efforts, had already localized powerful
burnings that could lead to very
large unpleasant ones, but the
burning continued to rob the reactor
, radioactive aerosols were released and
therefore the government commission of
debates and disputes felt that the
traditional methods that
were prepared at the station to localize
this accident were not  it will succeed over someone and in
such a
3 2 1 but it happened that the
idea of the same bolt was transmitted first to 50 meters.  [applause]
[music] the
job was to
drop with a helicopter into the destroyed
reactor after fire loads with on an
external sling, first sand then
lead dolomite boron
first of all we loaded somewhere 15
kilometers from the reactor, that is,
parachutes were loaded for us brake parachutes such
sandbags at first we took off
, such a conveyor passed in a circle,
up to 40 helicopters flew, which, with an interval of
2-3 minutes there, due to the fact that no one opened the windows, the
helicopter was closed, but
due to the fact that it was not sealed,
the
radiation did not steal everything  equally there, and the
view was of the
destroyed reactor, as after the fire,
some lines
in the first days were observed as red ones
from a height of 200 meters,
this already happened later when they started
building on the maps and this helicopter just
caught on the screen cable,
which was already standing to service the
construction of the sarcophagus
and
reflections from  the sun beam to the floor we
happened to see the
dismantling of the crane radiation she  it is read
as invisible, it cannot be seen there, but
you can feel it, that is, there is a
metallic taste in the mouth and a sore
throat, radiation does not pass without a trace,
therefore
there are always consequences and radiation affects exactly
those parts of the body that are most
susceptible or
vulnerable, let’s say, to order, you were brought up,
after all, we are late in Bryansk,
although  we called on the formant davi
free porno comedy movie chair over the
back.
his style is the president forex habit for the
epson printer
to give my faces in bright wetsuits, I
put on myself completely
from below and
everything was closed up to here, that is, if there was water there,
was there something like that, then it didn’t
get inside, I
went because I understood that if you
walk for a long time  very quietly, the dose will
increase with us if there was
already this yes and now you walk on them on water
on water it was necessary to know how these
are the things from which she removes the
water to open them that's why it turned out
that you need to climb this long
how  it’s called a
pipe, yes, this long pipe, it was a
little higher and there was water everywhere, it was possible
to run across this one,
I took a
flashlight, why does it turn on the flashlight everywhere,
you can turn it on and check everything, that
is, one of here put the second one on your leg
and  when I went through everything, I returned, I
handed it over to people who checked if I
have a large dose there or here,
they would tell me to go to the doctors or
do yourself like this here on  before such
things in order to make me feel better,
no one said that,
well, I explain why I confused mine,
they checked there were no such moments that
I had a large dose, I worked there and
paid the money I earned, so to
say that I won’t do it, I think that
later it’s hard
to get another job, because everyone will
know that I was not needed where I was not needed, I
refuse, you all know, recently we were in
trouble the
accident at the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant,
it painfully affected the Soviet people, it
excited the international community,
for the first time we really encountered such a
formidable force as nuclear
energy emerged from  -under control
today 299 people were hospitalized with a
diagnosis of radiation sickness of varying
severity seven of them died
more freely taught that  what kind of
chemical protection is active protection for this words,
all of us really haven’t seen it, we’ve come
now, I’ll say specifically,
it means that on the fifth day
I didn’t start to suffocate, I practically didn’t eat at all, so the
inquisitor zinchuk smear envy with pins
and according to Usain, after all, we need his
nasal phrase  campaigns in afghanistan
and where to go, it’s not me, so my neighbor,
someone needs to go, someone needs to
clean up all this muck, so they didn’t ask
first, you see first there who do
n’t have children and they took
[music]
under thirty they didn’t take, but it’s already
February-March  in the month of April, the urgent
welders were already driven away,
I personally saw with my own eyes the soldier
service of 18-year-olds, this is
why I cook when already at the end before the
demobilization on May 22, I gathered certificates that I received on the field
trips as a
chemist, I was seventy-six-
odd X-rays taken
at the maximum rate  25 to this they gave 25
2496 24 whole and 1 6 cal doses because
it was impossible to give higher and they
went home
and we are the liquidators, we are all cannon fodder  in
short, they changed us cannon fodder, together with two or three
parties to a party of 600 to 800 people,
no one knows how many people
Chernobyl died, the right disease,
everyone else went on the
word radiation about diseases in general and deleted
it from medical terminology,
it’s sad for us to be  the right to disease of
all that
redmine forum with a spout function a
fox
bunch often to get help me to work to
have im degrees 200 ml
savostin britvin sides to stuffing
textiles
1st with can clip from you know i vs
interlink command grand auto under the eyes
grimacing kachis forever line for the  money so
since the it functions a very we are looking for pour
these from the minister shadov met with us
at the market in chernobyl in an empty city
an empty market and he began to say the guys
need to do their job and you will
receive five times more than a tunneller
in civilian life
and the one who  well, let's say he decides to be too lazy, we will
call him through the military registration and enlistment office, but when
we realized that we just need to save it and
the world and our country and the whole world there were no
thoughts of shirking or about
some money
when you start working in a mine you
forget about everything you need to do
work you have tasks you do it
and all there are no distractions for anything to
understand only  the physical track that
you determine how you do it faster and
better
they are afraid of anyone for
two minutes to load this trolley
150 meters drive unload
and drive again I have never
seen this and will never see it again and it is
unlikely that anyone else will be able
to do this here  this enthusiasm that I saw there,
it never starts, therefore,
any heat, yes, it was all the same, the ladies
were through from the bot, our T-shirts, pants, and there
were boots, they were rags,
it was the uniform of the atomic workers.  everything
was soaking wet but we don’t take it off
everything that was required of us we did
it it was required of us in 6 months you
passed in 4
but what if it went differently and g 1
everything suddenly justified started to fail
and we didn’t do our job then  it was
worse for everyone, not for us, everything is even good
that we won’t need it, it’s good, we live while we’re
alive, we rejoice, we enjoy life, and we work with
children and tell the children everything,
tell everyone what
happened and so that this doesn’t
happen again, unfortunately, friends leave
and we once-  then we’ll leave, but always when we
bury
and speaking at the commemoration, I’ll admit, yes,
I say he was such a person, he did
such an act of
heroic life that few people managed to
do in life and he didn’t live on
earth for nothing, I also didn’t live on earth for nothing,
once I  I'll leave and I will also be
counted as a hell of a bow to
fiction in this service tass our us
all september the builder of the work followed
to support the end and on the roofs lay
nuclear fuel  huge hundreds of tons not a
kilogram hundreds of tons
sometimes shaben your second boss is some
kind of dead
it's skype systems it's marcelo and cracks we have
time for the background act
[music]
airbus
well for us buy la paz
well, then the gap in this he does not
sit saddened by the shores  to do well,
whether it’s Chernobyl, which means, either
Yura Samoilenko suggested it,
or Shcherbina himself, but the word
such bio
robots popped up, but what can I say about salt soldiers and
it won’t work from the number, and what is the
biorobots soldier sent, he so by that fact
wear your hand with your hands  nikolaevich but there is no
other option
[music]
but dance with other jobs questions antique
liters clean to the maximum in mantissa
kins
[music]
well, this is the worst thing, and so the
soldiers in a pose should show,
you will see pieces of this body, so you should
take tongs or a grip  and
pull and and drop this 4 block
wreck red tape was so bad
shown in this movie drop but
you have to look down come up after the
shock you go there either 50 meters d  the hollow
called out there and there will be nothing left for you
[music]
when I performed in the creation, keep in mind
that you are volunteers, which means you know and miss
defense and that’s all
if someone doesn’t agree get out of
order before it’s too late it’s clear all of you
no one will roll forward blowing it  your
life
and
and span 1000 passed none
refused well and of course we all
eluded the life of a person how is it
possible
x
[music]
music]
but we often go here very much to
Volodya earlier it was more unfortunately
the number of people who
come here is decreasing
[music]
radiation is an invisible enemy
but relentless and he caught up with them all
[music]
Poltava Shevchenko Maxim Shevchenko
Mr.
apache but was also
looking for senpai help both are
rude used in this ensures
shevchenko ate people on the elevator
[music]
lecture krymchan us be so i do it now is
but do it is worth it  tsya and when the valga
speed
on the screen is one of the frames that are
studio ones.  at first he delayed the
marriage not tomi marriage photos visible
liquidations look
this very first short shot was taken
when they were allowed to get up from the hatch of an armored personnel carrier
with a movie camera
only for 30 seconds tried to film
what was happening in the country and all the horror of
this Chernobyl felt sorry for the insanely young
soldiers who were sent when
Japanese robots refused then and sent
recruits to clean up this graphite and all
Volodya was madly worried about it, but the camera
that was filmed
by Shevchenko’s group Taranchenko Krivchenko I
couldn’t take Shevchenko’s
X-ray so much that it couldn’t be
activated without activating it and they just buried
Volodya destroyed the radiation lungs were burned
when they operated on him  to trample on
his operating rooms just crumbled and
all the doctors gave a non-disclosure agreement,
then they hid how dangerous Chernobyl was
and all the doctors gave a
subscription and when by chance 1 doctor
got into a conversation so she begged me not
to extradite me because she would be liable
under the law for divulging secrets  s
that he died and he had
radiation lungs
bring something to eat, but I
cursed and started kissing and saying
that
I’m always faithful to what
Volodya will endure and then recover, well,
when I arrived with the broth,
they moved the gurney past me,
it turns out there  there was Shevchenko and I even
said Shevchenko to me,
but they quickly left and didn’t let me
say goodbye and everything and everything was hidden and even Vladimir’s medical card, this thing was
requested by the Moscow Ministry of Health,
you will write this whole for the president, the
beauty of the table, and you
line again writes the son to meet up to 5  sky
now the information has become so much more
that it’s even hard to imagine the new
generation doesn’t know that we lived in conditions of
extremely limited information and we
didn’t have many rights, we relied on one
truth, well, the truth was also a
lie, invested in the final analysis,
I worked very much in the zone  for many years I
thought the feeling
was all over but nevertheless
[music]
list of which I rarely visit they
still cause some kind of children  what
memories
this is a former pioneer camp fabulous
it was a camp for Pripyat children with a
sports bias I personally spent
two shifts here 80 years and 84 years up to 85 times the
month of June both years very vivid pleasant
memories also this place became the
first camp for participants in the
aftermath of the accident and lived here  they
rested, including on the same tone, they held discos from the site
,
I think that all the same, for the most
part, these people were those who came here
voluntarily, they could not
really understand what they were going for, even though they
realized something dangerous, approximately
estimated their strengths, but  if they
globally understood the consequences, that is,
that they will lose their health, someone
will lose their life, someone will lose loved ones,
who still does not have a state, after many
years they will be left with nothing
without fulfilling their obligations, I think
that very many probably well you
thought about it if  before there was a
Soviet Union, then we could say
this catastrophe 15 of these republics by and
large  now, not a single country in the
world can cope with such problems,
it lives for some reason and I just went in and
it’s not very sharp, I remembered how we
lit big fires and played modern music there as children,
something that was impossible even in Pripyat at that
time foreign performers  and we
danced the first attempts at a
relationship with the girl is difficult and I
don’t even know how to describe it, this is
some sort of return of the
unfulfilled future, can you
imagine how it could well
be now
[music]
like they fired the second volley of china port
outcome from 3  -x on the ice personally for the luck of the
camarilla casually amazing desi deign
court shoes
defile for the black queen feature zanks l.v.
[music]
and orsk easygo
it is sacred for us because the place is
communication with Volodya with all the soul and when we
light a candle it seems to us that it is
Volodya's soul that comes to us
when the candle burns brightly it seems that
Volodya communicates with us like this
[music]